whatever happened to the doctor that
accidentally punctured Tyrod Taylor's
lungs in case you don't remember tirod
was a starting quarterback for the
Chargers in 2020 he re-aggravated a rip
injury during pregame warm-ups in week
two that required a painkiller injection
but the doctor Dave gazaniga
accidentally punctured Tyrod Taylor's
lung while giving him the injection that
forced him to lose the starting spot to
Justin Herbert who took off and never
looked back the accident never sat well
with Tyrod he decided to take action two
years later he ended up suing gazaniga
for malpractice in 2022 and at least
five million dollars well you won't
believe this gazaniga still works for
the Chargers he even oversaw the group
that treated Justin Herbert for his rib
injury last season so what happened to
the rest of tyrod's NFL career he ended
up settling as a backup for the Texans
and most recently the Giants and Herbert
is a top QB in the league but it's still
disappointing that Tyrod never got a
shot at starting for the Chargers all
for what was supposed to be a simple
painkiller injection